artists make things not because the
things they make are special but because
making is special for us we are makers
we are as human beings manufacturers if
you go back 30 thousand years to the
dawn of the psychologically modern human
being what what seems to inaugurate that
beginning is precisely this this
explosion of making practices of tool
tool making and tool using practices and
pictorial practices and linguistic
practices and clothing we are makers and
I think that artists make things to
unveil that fact about ourselves so I I
say that works of art are strange tools
they're not just they're not just more
tools with this or that function or
application their tools that in their
strangeness are meant to exhibit the
place that tools and technology have in
our lives too often i think when we come
to think about art if we're scientists
or cognitive scientists or philosophers
is we think of art as if it were a
phenomenon something that we can put
under glass and explain the view that
i've come to is that actually art is
itself its own research practice its
itself a way of trying to understand the
world and ourselves and that a better
strategy for for trying to really get a
handle on the questions that that
interest us what is art why does art
matter so much what does what does the
fact that it matters so much tell us
about ourselves it's actually to look at
art as our collaborator rather than the
object of our investigation the art
situation becomes an opportunity to
really put one's own perceptual
consciousness or other aspects of one's
consciousness one's understanding sort
of
interview for oneself and that's one of
the reasons why i like to say that art
is something like a philosophical
practice because what I've just said
about our really is paradigmatically
philosophical this idea that art or
philosophy are somehow in the business
of unveiling us to ourselves and in
doing that supplying us with resources
to change